nous sommes sur le mississipi un fleuve
mythique de 3700 km qui traverse les
états unis du nord au sud
nous débarquons acquéreurs dans l'état
de l'illinois qui o
en arrivant dessins de désolation aux
attentes
les maisons s'écroulent il n'ya plus
d'épicerie et l'hôpital est abandonné le
centre-ville de kerlo est mort qui
anthony cheng li est le seul parmi ses
huit frères et soeurs qui est resté il
est postier et joue de l'orgue dans une
des ses églises encore debout dans cette
ville meurtrie par le racisme
pourtant de 1900 à 1960 kerleau et
prospère une cité vibrante de 15000
habitants à majorité blanche
mais les noirs sont exclues de la vie
économique et sociale
le premier maire afro-américain de kyoto
a été victime de cette ségrégation dans
sa jeunesse
à la fin des années 60 les noirs
minoritaire en ont assez ils boycottent
les commerces des blancs qui refuse de
les embaucher
la lutte pour les droits civiques
transforme kerleau en champ de bataille
les blancs abandonne la ville au lieu de
céder aux demandes des noirs c'est le
début de la fin aujourd'hui plus
personne ne souhaite investir ou vivre
ici
la population a dégringolé à 2400
habitants en majorité noire
le chanteur sting lui a consacré un
album complet il a passé cinq ans à
tenter de comprendre l'histoire de la
ville l'ex maire est convaincu lui aussi
que le rascisme a tué en partie sa ville
sur la population noire vient encore
aujourd'hui dans des conditions
d'extrême pauvreté
cette femme demeure dans ce complexe
d'habitation devenu un ghetto beverly
davis reçoit de l'aide sociale elle paye
50 dollars par mois pour ce logement est
infesté de rats et de coquerelles
joint-ventures n'en peut plus de voir
six logements délabrés
il siège au conseil d'administration de
ces hlm où les blancs sont majoritaires
selon lui ils négligent ces habitations
où vivent surtout des afro-américains
gambien bcb de bras
si certains parlent ouvertement des
tensions raciales pour d'autres le sujet
demeure tabou
norbert est en panne
bref tout se pose ici la même question
quelle eau va-t-elle survivre n'ont mis
en garde dès 15 ans
l'avenir de kerho repose peut-être sur
ses jeunes ses enfants un soutien qui
peuvent encore rêver qu'un jour blanc et
noirs vivrons ego le long du mississippi
non
où